uh you cannot accuse me of insurrection  I was a victim of the January 6 Riot  just as much as any other member of  Congress that was the third day I had on  the job I had nothing to do with what  happened there that day and I will not  have you accuse me of that that is wrong  of you to do you're lying about me and  you will not defame my character in that  manner did Joe Biden win the election  congresswoman Greene Joe Biden is the  president of the United States  understand that that's how they avoid it  they say he is the president but they  won't say he won absolutely but you  pushed a big lie that said he did not  win the election  he drove those people to the Capitol on  January 6.  we're going to move on Josh  and my question  my husband has proof that's another one  of the lies she's been telling  um Marcus flowers is really good and  sadly I don't think he stands a chance  from the little polling I've seen